I love that big nuts in my chocolate
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's up I'm Sam Ryder and I'm here
at LAD Bible to do snack Wars UK versus
Europe we're doing UK versus Europe
because of Eurovision and frankly we
couldn't think of anything more
um worthy of the whole Eurovision thing
happening than to have a kind of uh
coliseum-esque Battle of the snacks who
polishes this because this is that
anyway all right okay
um Greg's vegan sausage roll I presume
and a a croissant from the continent
all of these snacks are vegan which
means they're going to be subpar to what
the normal
Taste of the snacks would be but um I
feel the French would turn in their
graves with a vegan
I'm actually really hungry listen
it's going to be the Greg sausage roll
because
the technology sorry mum for talking my
mouthful shoes I told her I was on snack
with she was like don't you dare bloody
chat with your mouthful hey Siri sorry
sir as well I've got you covered the
technology isn't there yet in my opinion
for a good vegan croissant but good
vegan sausage roll Widow
oh I love these really yeah these are so
good these win it but I'm gonna have
everything anyway today yeah these
hundreds of Spanish yeah these cost a
fortune as well
oh what flavor is it money flavor
you basically just sending money truffle
black truffle yeah when you see these
like in a hotel or something like that
you know you're somewhere
yeah yes
truffle well
Skip's God bless them but they can't
compete what is your favorite UK thing a
Max Max paprika crisp like yeah I'd like
chucking those in a sandwich and then
yeah
yes it is these are wicked
it's a bit oh
it's all about all right
UK this is Britannic and um where are
these from Spanish Spanish Britannic
Fusion
the skip reduces the quality in such a
way that actually makes it it makes you
feel
I know
at home
it's like a bag of home there you are
subtle yeah right on Spain I'll be up
[Laughter]
so sauerkraut that sauerkraut's really
good for you isn't it yeah so this is a
Polish sauerkraut do you like it do you
have you have you had it before thank
you I thought I was about to just like
dig my paw in there I love soccer
right okay
so we've got sauerkraut I've had
sauerkraut before
um
[Music]
I see that I mean it that just smells
like home to me yeah going down the I
don't know my dad watching Formula One
and him having a
like a pack of peanuts and pickled eggs
it's not in a great escape
that's a lot of salt cheers
um
it feels good for you you know and it is
[Laughter]
when you breathe in when you've got a
pickled onion in your mouth
especially if you didn't have breakfast
yeah
sauerkraut wins blood on Poland yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah because I know that
I mean this has given me no nutritional
benefit but this
is great are you taking a video nah
oh okay yeah
this looks
like it's going to be a winner to me
really yeah because I can taste how
sugary that is no I mean it's got a
certain like nuclear glow to it so this
is Greek uh drink which is called
Lou okay probably and a classic ribena
I was thinking just then do you have to
shake who I've been of course you don't
no I don't think so I think it's good
unshaken
they've got rid of a lot of sugar from
that over the years really yeah yeah
that's it's um it's a husk of its former
self no offense ribena you're not
watching but
you don't shake this I'm guessing I have
a deal I don't know I guess it might
yeah no you know
that's wicked 100 Greek wins
three two why am i counting down for
myself
right no okay oh this looks fancy this
is the sort of thing that you'd get
for your parents at Christmas buy a
three for two ranging boots in it this
just looks fantastic
how are the levels of moisture and
everything in there really good yeah
good balance because it doesn't travel
well what is your take on Victoria
sponge what would you be your GTA sake
of choice yeah I do I love a red velvet
this have these ones been defrosted
these ones are damaged aren't they
so you're more of a red bevel person
yeah I do like red velvet I love um Thai
green curry that weren't the question
was it you're asking about cake yeah I
asked about dessert but I do love green
curry I do I do I do no I just love Kate
it's actually really that's annoyingly
good really that is throwing a big cake
shake spanner
in the works the cultured Man in Me
wants to pick this but just the greedy
yeah
I'm so sorry Wicked
oh it's the ultimate showdown
German that's the UK and you've got
vegan KitKat which I know I've had one
of these they are pretty close and then
they're wild and this though there's a
massive this
that's great let's start with the cake
how are you opening it are you opening
it like that now do you know what annoy
if my friend's watching this I want to
do something that I know will annoy him
okay because I know he loves snack Wars
is that yeah
I can't do that it's the most I hate
doing it but I know that he hates seeing
it more all right I mean that's so good
but it you know it's a KitKat I don't
want to lose my mind over just a kick up
crunchy hole hazelnuts
[Music]
yeah
really yep
I love that big nuts in my chocolate
I literally woke up this morning
and said to myself I'm that's it I'm not
having any more chocolate until the end
of Eurovision made you quite a lot of
sweets today sorry about that yeah thank
you very much you're watching are you
having an amazing time
Europe has won
the the snack wear that you guys have
provided and um brought to the the
actual table under the Cosh today is the
Cosh isn't it
it was unbeatable and um yeah you
deserve it so thank you very much for
having us and I need to eat a salad
immediately
um you guys good if I actually take this
oh hold on
there's not a lolly in it I've not got a
lolly
this is like a faulty packet
that is all all dip and no dab
[Music]
hello I'm Ed gamble James acaster here
and this is snack Wars for lab Bible